- Guys, once and for all,
this go outside and play shit
is bullshit, it's bullshit.
It's not been around for a very,
very, very, very long time.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 296
of the #AskGaryVee Show
and this is a very rare occurrence.
Is this the second, first,
how many people have we ever had on twice?
- [Andy] Casey.
- Casey.
- [Andy] And I think that's it.
- Oh wow.
So I'm second twice.
- And Charlemagne the
God's gonna be very upset
'cause I think he's booked soon
so Baby Ariel sneaks
under Charlemagne the God
to be the second ever two
time guest of our show.
- Well thank you for having me.
- It's great to have you.
There's so much to catch up on.
For everybody watching,
I guess three years ago,
you and your buddy at the time.
You guys still friends,
you guys talk?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's amazing, came through,
it was a big show about Musical.ly
and what was going on with
you two in that platform.
There's been a lot of things
I've predicted that would go well,
usually apps or things of that nature
but it makes me super happy
to have you here this morning
to see everything that's
been going on with you
over the last three years
and I'm sure there's some fun little quote
that the team will pull out.
I have a funny feeling
that this video will be
showing up in my social media
in about 18 to 24 months.
And now here we are the day
before your book's coming out.
- Yes.
- I've seen you doing
some real things in music
and film and TV.
So for me personally
and the people at home,
I'll just set the context.
You broke ou ton Musical.ly
on that platform,
became one of the most followed people.
You obviously like many people
transferred that attention
to other platforms
and have amassed a huge
following in other places,
Instagram and such,
but from the point when we last saw you,
over the last three years,
take it from, okay, I'm
crushing it on Musical.ly,
how did you get strategic
about siphoning that audience?
What then started happening?
What's it about?
And then more importantly,
what's the book about
and then most importantly
for the audience watching,
for all the people that are nine to 99
or what I think you have
an incredible story to tell
at some point,
probably not your biggest
passion right this minute
but I think you can have an
enormous impact on parents
and the way they think about
having their young kids
play on these platforms
because you've obviously,
so many people want to dwell
on things like bullying and negativity
but we're spending no time
or not enough time,
on the fact that it fundamentally
changed the course of your life.
- Exactly.
- And theoretically creates,
I don't want to count your
money or your happiness
but creates generational opportunities.
- 100%, yeah.
- That you're not even thinking about
nor should you at this point.
And that means a lot to me
and it's a very big thesis of
me and mine of the internet
and the things built on top of them.
People currently are
spending all their time
worrying about it
and I think that net, net,
it's creating so much
opportunity and happiness
and I don't think we
spend enough time on that.
So that's heavy stuff towards the end
but take me back to three
years ago, what progresses?
- So three years ago I started
on an app called Musical.ly
as you know
and one thing about me
is Musical.ly happened by accident,
I went on there for fun
and it was great
but I've been acting--
- You did that
as a normal kid.
- Exactly, a normal kid,
that was just what I did.
Same way you go on
Instagram, you go on Twitter
but I've been acting and
singing since I was little.
My dad is a musician,
my mom's an actress.
So once I started on Musical.ly,
I was like, okay, this
is great, I love it,
I love social media, I love to entertain
and this is happening,
let's see how we can use this platform
and build off of it.
I love social media
but I would want to continue with acting
and I wanted to continue with singing
and I wanted to continue
with everything like that.
So what's it called?
I used social media,
I started doing YouTube, Instagram
and everything like that,
met people in the music industry,
started playing around
with piano and singing
and created some songs,
worked more on my acting
and it took time
but yeah, started writing my book.
- What is the book about?
- The book is really my journal entries
and my stories and
anecdotes about growing up,
about my first day of school,
about self love,
it talks a lot about social
media and cyber bullying
and confidence
and my stories
and whether they're sad, happy, whatever
and how I learned from those events
and how other kids can learn
from what happened to me,
my real stories
and my advice based on what happened.
Things like your first day of school
or your first kiss or your crush
or even loving yourself and social media
and the world that
social media is right now
and how we have to stay
confident in who we are
and we can't compare ourselves to others
and my experience on social media
with being a social media person
and being compared to other people
and how I got through that
and how kids, whatever scale they are
in social media--
- What was your biggest
insecurity hurdle?
No bullshit, for real, for real,
obviously, when you're on
the Today Show or Real TV
or things of that nature,
you're gonna have to be
a little more vanilla,
like on this platform--
- Exactly.
- For the people that watch,
to really truly make an impact for you,
what was really truly the biggest
thing you had to get over?
- My real insecurity I think was
my body, I want to say and looks
because I've always been
confident in my personality is me,
this is me, I'm me
but I was never so aware
of the way I looked
and suddenly I was making Musical.ly's
and I was taking pictures of myself
and nobody'd heard the
sound of my voice before,
they just saw me creating
these lip sync videos
and it was all looks
and it was all the way I was
and I was never so--
- You were also, what, 14?
- 14, yeah.
So I was never so aware of myself.
- More importantly,
you're talking about an age
where look, this is what
men and women go through
but obviously I think women
go through it earlier.
There's this transition where like,
as a dad of a young woman
and I'm sure a lot of people
can relate to this,
four seconds ago you're
like watching YouTube,
making slime or dressing
up in the living room
and five seconds later, makeup
and whispering about boys
and looking at your body in the mirror.
That, and whether it happens,
some people it happens 11 and 12
and some people it happens at 16
but whenever it happens, it's big.
- Yeah, for sure,
and I think that's what definitely,
I was starting Musical.ly
and this whole thing
and getting looked at at that age
where I was just starting to
become comfortable with myself.
So I had to learn how to
be comfortable with me
while other people were learning how to,
were learning about me and who I was
and I think that was,
it was definitely the hardest challenge,
that's something that I
talk about in the book.
- Did you find yourself
spending or dwelling
over comments about weight
or pimples or things?
Looking back, and I remember,
'cause I was interested
in that at the time,
especially for the Musical.ly stars
'cause it went so much younger because--
- Yeah, a lot younger.
- A lot younger.
And for me it's all psychology
and I want to learn, excuse me,
and I remember thinking,
so what I do a lot is read comments
more so than look at content, excuse me.
And so you would get
thousands of comments,
94% of which were positive and great,
but six percent's still a lot.
And more importantly, you
could get 9,000 comments,
if only one is negative
at that age and that--
- It affects you, for sure and that was,
I looked at a ton of my comments
because that, at the time,
because it wasn't like,
okay, let's build off of Musical.ly,
let's build off of Instagram,
my psychology at that time
was just oh this is fun
and I'm gaining a following.
I was 14,
in the first few months we're just,
let's see what people say.
- Let me ask you a question
'cause I think this is
also very important,
with parents that were in entertainment
or had entertainment skills,
you couldn't have been 100% like whoa,
it had to be somewhere
in the back of your mind
of like, wait a minute, this could be,
even at 14,
if you're always singing and dancing
and things of that nature at a young age,
you could've been 93% human,
but seven percent or two
percent or nine or 13%
had to be like hmmm, if
this really takes off,
maybe something.
- It was weird,
at the beginning,
it wasn't even I was new to Musical.ly,
I was new to social media in general.
- Was that the first platform you were on?
Because by the time you came and saw me,
you were talking about Twitter
being big in high school
and things of that nature.
But was Musical.ly a couple years earlier
the first thing you were on
or the second?
- It was a collection,
that's when I just got
my iPhone, for example,
so that was when I was
just being introduced
and this was, the beginning
was very like what is happening
and over time, I think, I
want to say the third month
is when we,
I remember sitting down
as a family saying,
okay, we're gaining a following,
we're getting an Instagram following,
Twitter following,
let's create a YouTube
channel, for example,
let's open up her LLC and the website
and everything like that.
So it was pretty quick
but those first few weeks/first month
were just kind of like
wrapping our heads around
what is this as a whole?
- At the time, when you
were huge on Musical.ly,
but I remember being excited
and thought it was funny
and couldn't wait to see
how it would play out
in the fact that at high school,
it still wasn't like you were completely
getting mobbed by it,
that some people knew
but I assume because of what happened
on Instagram and YouTube after,
and I don't know if you're like,
did you have to leave school?
Like what's happened with your career?
Do you get home schooled,
did you stay in school?
What did you do?
- Yeah, so at that time,
I was going into ninth grade
and I got approached for my first tour
and the tour was a month long tour.
And we talked to the office,
the school office, it was either,
really it was either you stay in school
and you do social media,
you continue Musical.ly
or let's go for it
kind of thing.
- And that's what you did?
- [Baby Ariel] And that's what we did.
- Got it, makes sense, totally understand.
And so over the last
three years of growth,
what would you say has been
the biggest eye opener,
what did you anticipate,
'cause at that point again,
I think you and the fam,
I remember talking to the fam,
had a good understanding,
wasn't like complete, it was early
but you had a lot of
followers at that point.
Over the last three years
what's been the biggest surprise to you?
What didn't you see happening
or what played out way
different than you thought?
- I want to say,
singing and acting,
truthfully, singing and
acting and this whole,
when I started,
for me, Musical.ly and YouTube,
I don't know why in my head,
it wasn't as big as it was in my--
- Well it's funny you say that,
I think I remember telling you guys,
no, no, no, no, no, this is Hollywood,
keep doing this
and Hollywood will follow it
instead of stop this and go,
I don't know what exactly,
I see you shaking your head,
it was definitely like no,
no, no, guys, this is it.
- And I think that was like,
even though, people were
like this is it, this is it
but coming to the
realization of like oh no,
this is actually it.
- Like I'm more famous than people on TV
and other places
but because I'm bigger on
this platform was still hard
because even though you were young and in,
still television and film is on a pedestal
and I will say this,
I think we're just at the cusp
where the nine year old you,
Susan in Tennessee
is starting to be 50/50
where an Instagram or YouTube celebrity
is equal to a Nickelodeon
television celebrity
and then I think in six years
it will be first phone, second television.
- Mmhmm, 100%.
I think now, you see some of these
YouTube videos, for example,
are getting longer and longer,
they're more episodes,
there's different series
that I'm watching on YouTube, for example
and it's more of this is television
because kids can look up
whatever they want now.
- And I apologize for cutting you off,
and grown ups have smart televisions
and watching a show on YouTube now
is something a 47 year old
can actually click two buttons and do
and that was the big turning point.
What people don't understand
is the kids are always gonna,
we're always, like I'm a kid, but kids--
- Like us.
- Us kids, kids are always gonna adapt
to the new thing very easily
and parents are always gonna
be like, what's this VCR?
Like I used to have to help
set up a VCR or a Nintendo
but once 30 to 70 can use that technology
it becomes the technology.
The fact that Netflix and YouTube
are apps on smartphones changed everything
'cause now those people aren't stuck
on channels two through 63.
- Exactly and I think now with kids too,
it used to be,
even with the radio and TV,
there were certain things
that were being fed to them,
like this show at this time
and this song on this station
at this time and that was it
where now kids really have
the control to look up
whatever they want,
they can watch whatever they want.
- But you know what's funny, Ariel,
what blows me away is that's right
and yet every day I have to talk to kids
about putting out more songs
on Spotify and SoundCloud
because they're still,
even though they know that,
once they become the artist,
they still succumb to the old machine.
- Exactly.
- They still want to get A&R'ed,
they still want to get on iHeart's tour,
which is great,
but the reality is the great thing is
you literally got a
smartphone, got on Musical.ly
and here you are
and it is not as rare as people think.
You're at a top of the
heap in a certain demo
but the long tail of you,
AKA, I'm gonna say it very basic
since this is a business show,
yes, they'll be people
who have the potential to
make seven and more figures
but there are so many people
that can make $59,000 a
year doing what they love
versus making $59,000 a year
doing something they don't love
and that is game changing.
- No 100%.
- Facebook, I know you're watching live,
please put in your questions.
I see Andy carefully
going through it right now
trying to find questions
but put in your phone number as well
'cause I will call somebody.
I'm sure somebody watching right now
has a child that would lose their mind
to talk to Baby Ariel
and so if you want to
pull them out of school,
or it's actually a day off at school,
this is huge, wake up your kid
who's probably still sleeping
and give them a shot.
We'll take some phone numbers.
Please, put your phone numbers in
and reference in the comments
if you have your kid with you
who has a question for Baby Ariel.
Talk to me,
one thing that I was very excited about
when we talked off
camera after that episode
was I did see the business
savvy in the collective team,
you yourself as a real young girl
and your parents and the whole thing,
have you enjoyed the business part
or is this more about holy shit,
I may win a Grammy or an Academy Award?
Where are you in your head?
- I lead more with emotion in my heart
and I trust my gut, I want to say.
I really go with who I know I am
and depending on what
brands want to work with me,
who am I,
do I genuinely want to
work with that brand?
Because my whole Instagram, my everything,
I always want to be my
true authentic self.
- And the beauty is, right,
and again, I want to do
this for the audience,
it gets nice when you can
get to the top of the heap
and you can pass on things
that would've made your head
spin just three years ago.
- Exactly.
- When I pass on speaking
somewhere for $125,000
and that is more than I made
for the whole year when
I was 28 years old,
there's never a time I
take that for granted.
I can't wrap my head around,
wait a minute, I just said no
to go to Vegas for two hours
and literally five minutes ago,
which is what it feels like,
that's how much I made
for the entire year.
That must be crazy when you're
turning down a brand deal
from a water or a makeup
and you would've cried out
of happiness four years ago
for a third of that much.
- Yeah, I think as time goes on
and as you keep building
and as I get more knowledgeable
about this business
and who I am and who I want to be
and everything going on,
like you said, I have had brand deals
that I know four years
ago would have been,
the first thing that happened to me
was this brand on Instagram was like,
oh, we can send you free clothing
if you post a picture--
- And you lost your mind.
- And I was, that was it for me.
- You made it.
- Yeah, that was it.
This company wants to send
me free clothes and I was--
- Now if that company offers you 200,000,
you spit on them like
Khabib spit on McGregor.
I get it, I get it, I do
and listen, I think
people watching are like,
that's crazy or that seems ridiculous
but it's like anything else,
once your life gets contextualized,
it becomes contextualized.
You can't unwind where you're at.
What's the biggest thing
that you haven't done yet
that you think about
for the next half decade
that gets you excited?
- For me, my dream,
I would definitely want
to put out an album
and hopefully just,
either be able to direct a movie
or do another movie
or produce a movie or write,
going forward I feel like I have,
I don't want to say,
I have my base of everything that I love
and I just want to continue learning
about each space and building
off of what I am doing.
Mentally in myself wise,
just seeing what I'm able to do
and go from there kind of thing.
- That makes sense to me.
Have you or your team,
parents and things of that nature,
have you sniffed out though
that when you go more into
the mature industries,
the flexibility gets sucked out?
To me the fascinating thing,
and I think you're a beacon,
you're an example for me,
the five to seven
Musical.ly stars or YouTube,
I think about you,
I put you in my music playlist
when your song came out,
so obviously that was so fun
when you guys came on the show for me
for a lot of reasons
'cause it's a moment in time,
it's why I like filming
and this will be another moment in time
and I'm sure when we're super old
we'll do another video,
it'll be fun to mash 'em all together.
- Like hi, we're back.
- But I am fascinated
by the enormous freedom
that social media is
and the heavy economics,
brands reaching out
and then going into album land, movie land
where everything's much slower,
much more restricted.
Have you felt any of those things
as you've gone into some mainstream stuff?
You're like, whoa, I didn't realize,
have you seen that?
- No 100%.
Like you said, I'm so used
to producing something
and creating a video
and it was up to me.
- Full control, right?
- If I want to post it, I can post it
and it's my image and it's who I am,
this is my Instagram
and now I remember when
I was filming the movie,
on the first day, I did a one take
and my initial was like,
okay, let me watch that back
and I can't watch that tape back,
I don't know what's
happening or even with music,
I record and I write,
I'll go into sessions,
and the people that I'm working with,
if they don't like a
certain song for right now,
that song's not coming out right now.
I could love a song
and if it's not right for right now,
it's not right for right now.
Whereas maybe me just by myself,
I would've put that song out.
- I gotta tell you,
all my spidey senses,
I'm super fascinated by this,
I genuinely believe what I'm about to say,
the nine year old you
is just not gonna go into the system,
I really believe that.
I believe that you came in,
so here's how it worked,
1987, 2002, people went into
the system with no control,
they got picked, they got lucky, the A&Rs,
people that would go to
bars in places picking
that's the next Metallica,
wow, that's how you made it,
you're the next regime which is
you created it,
thus giving you the leverage,
thus everybody wanted to work with you
but when you went into the system,
you have to then work within them.
I think the next version
is just direct-to-consumer
because what I know
is I just believe that you're more likely
to be right about the song you love
than the people in the middle
between you and the end audience
because you were a creature
of producing to the audience
and the people that we
work with in mainstream
are creatures of the middle.
- Exactly.
- Interesting stuff.
Okay, we got questions?
- [Andy] We do.
- Go ahead.
You gonna ask or you gonna call?
- [Andy] Call.
- Alright, we're about to do a call.
- Woo!
- I'm gonna ask you in a little bit
so you should give it some thought,
who you think is doing interesting stuff
as people on social media?
I'm very curious what a social
media savant winner star
is seeing in the trenches
of who they think are
doing interesting stuff.
Who's this?
- [Andy] Kate.
- Kate, awesome.
Let's see what Kate has for Baby Ariel.
- Hey Kate.
- I assume the book is on Amazon now?
- Yes, for preorder.
- And have you been pushing preorder
or have you been waiting for it to launch?
- I have been pushing a little preorder
but I know, I'm waiting till tomorrow
to like just go hard.
- Go hard.
Kate, don't miss your chance.
- I know, come on, Kate.
- This is devastating for Kate.
- We're really disappointed.
- Yeah Kate, we're really upset with you.
Alright, hold on, hopefully
she has an answering machine,
we can leave her a devastating--
- [Kate] Hey it's Kate.
Leave a message and I'll call you back
as soon as I can, thank you.
- This is perfect.
- [Female] At the tone,
please record your message.
When you've finished recording,
you may hang up or press
one for more options.
(beeping)
- Hey Kate, it's Gary Vee and Baby Ariel.
- Hi.
- We're very sad that we missed
this once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to chat with you.
- We were very excited
and you didn't answer.
- That's right.
And we were more excited of talking to you
than even the book coming out tomorrow.
- I know, come on.
- Kate, we're sorry, we
will never call you back,
see you, bye.
- Bye.
- Alright, we'll go to the next one.
While Andy's pulling it up,
who is catching your eye in social?
Who do you think is
doing interesting stuff?
- Right now, Shane Dawson.
- Why?
- I don't even want to
get into what I think
about the series and
everything, what he's saying
but I do admire that he is putting out
this different format of YouTube
and it's not just
here's a five minute--
- Documentaries,
deep, deep, deep diving
into subjects, storytelling.
- Exactly.
And just the okay with oh,
here's a longer YouTube video
that feels like a TV show.
- Yep, I get it, really
interesting format.
Are you spending a lot of time--
- [Michelle] Hello.
- [Andy] Michelle.
- Michelle, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on the #AskGaryVee
Show with Baby Ariel.
How are you?
- [Michelle] I'm great, how are you Gary?
- I'm doing super well.
Say hello to Baby Ariel.
- [Michelle] Hi, Baby Ariel.
- Hi Michelle.
- [Michelle] How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- What's your question?
- Very well, thank you.
- Do you have a question?
- [Michelle] Oh, my question,
my question was--
- You've got this.
- [Michelle] You caught me off guard.
- I mean, I don't know how much
we could catch you off guard.
You did put your phone
number into a stream.
- Into the live stream.
- [Michelle] I think one of my questions
was life, was it the life coach question?
- You can ask anything you want,
it doesn't matter what you put into the--
- [Andy] You caught my eye with Snapchat,
that was the question
that I was looking at.
- Oh, Andy was excited
about your Snapchat question.
- [Michelle] Yes, I have two teenage kids
on Snapchat and everything
and it's such a great platform
but it's such a bad
platform, don't you think?
- Well, how old are your kids
and why do you think it's bad?
- Yeah.
- [Michelle] Okay, 15, 17.
- Okay.
- [Michelle] And Snapchat
disappears, right?
- Right.
- [Michelle] So these kids
are growing up in a society
of sending things out and
everything disappearing
and they have no accountability
for anything that they're
doing but then when--
- Michelle, let's talk about this.
You and I grew up in a world
where everything we did disappeared,
there was no documentation.
- [Michelle] Correct.
- When you went on your phone--
- [Michelle] It wasn't as
instantaneous as this is.
This is instantaneous.
- Sure it was.
Yours was instantaneous too.
When you went in your
room, locked your door
and called your girlfriend
on the phone and said stuff,
it would disappear.
As a matter of fact,
it never had the chance of appearing,
everything was disappearing
in the way that we grew up, right?
- [Michelle] True, true but I
think this is more dangerous.
- Well tell me
why it's more dangerous.
- Why?
- [Michelle] Well because I think
they don't understand at their age
everything that they're doing.
- Are you talking about,
well let's define it.
Are you talking about sending
each other nude pictures?
- [Michelle] Yes, absolutely.
- That's fine.
But I think what really
where you have to take this
is where does that all go?
So I think couple things,
one, for all these nudes
that everyone's sending,
there's two things that
I always tell parents.
Number one, it's remarkable
in these trillions of
nudes that are being sent,
how none of them are showing
up in other places, right.
Number two, a lot of
parents call me and go,
"Gary, I'm scared if my son,
"girls mature faster than boys,"
it's really interesting,
I think people are really surprised
where most of my DMs
come from from parents.
It's more parents of boys
worried that girls mature faster
and they don't want
their boys being spoiled.
And I laugh and I'm
like, I'm being serious
and I laugh and I go--
- [Michelle] But I so agree with that.
- See, see?
- Wait, what'd you say?
- She agrees with that.
Here's what I always
remind parents, Michelle.
I remind them that their boys
have the internet on Safari on their phone
and they are far more
likely to go to PornHub
than they are to get a nude
from some girl in their class
and there's a naivete and a fear
that's associated with parenting,
look, Michelle,
your brothers, if you had 'em,
or your friends in your class,
they went to 7-Eleven and stole Playboys,
boys will be boys at some level,
maturity's gonna happen.
15 and 17 year olds
are gonna live through their thing.
I think we as parents
fear new technologies
without fully going through them
in like what's actually happening.
Because again, our generation
we're renting VHSs from the video store
and waiting for parents
to leave to watch a porn.
There's this extreme
demonization of new technologies
while humans are still acting the same.
- [Michelle] Yes, I do
agree with you to some point
I just think that it's
definitely a bad platform too.
- Yeah, but you haven't given the,
I want to agree with you
if you would give me
something that is tangible.
Saying that 15 and 17 year olds
don't fully understand
is a universal statement.
You and I at 15 to 17 didn't understand.
- [Michelle] Here's another one.
- Gimme.
- [Michelle] A friend of mine's son
posted a picture of a hand gun
but it was really just an Airsoft gun
and he got suspended from
school, no tolerance.
So he didn't realize what he was doing,
he thought he was being cool.
- I got it, but couple
things, couple things.
Let's talk about being
suspended from school first.
Let's actually play it out.
How devastating or upsetting
is that in the macro?
For me, it's a non event in actual life.
It may be embarrassing for the mom
to have to explain that to the other moms
but in the scheme of human life,
being suspended from school
feels awfully minor.
And I can tell you 87 different stories.
In my school, there was
something called pantsing.
There was a very big thing
that happened in junior
year of my high school.
Here's what it was about.
You would, and people are laughing,
so I guess it was universal,
not just in Jersey in the '90s,
pantsing in my high school
was you would walk in the halls
and people would try to
pull down your entire pants.
- Oh my God.
- They still do that.
They still do it.
- Great.
So multiple kids in my
school got suspended
for pulling the pants down
of both boys and girls,
literally walking through my high school,
I would see naked kids
because somebody was behind
them and literally, not only,
and if you were really good at it,
you could also get the
underwear which is extremely--
- That's terrible.
- I'm being dead serious.
So I don't know, I don't
want to call out their names
because a lot of people
watching this shit now
but people got suspended in my school
for pantsing a girl in the
middle of the whole school,
that's also embarrassing.
That wasn't Snapchat.
Snapchat's not dangerous,
kids are doing dumb shit from 13 to 20
because that's the evolution of a human.
That's where I would go with it.
I don't think Snapchat is the problem
in the scenario of kid
putting up a foam gun.
I think kids do dumb shit
and they play out
digitally or in real life.
I would ask parents across America,
what's worse, foam gun on Snapchat,
by the way, in today's environment,
so I have empathy,
or boy pulling down girl's pants,
catches underwear
and she's naked in front
of the entire school.
Both feel pretty difficult to be palpable.
What I'm saying is, do you
know how much dumb shit
kids are doing in real life
and you have no idea they're doing it
because it's not being documented?
- [Michelle] And I'll
never say not my kid either
because you just never know,
it could be my kid tomorrow.
- Yeah, I think it depends
on the person really.
I don't think it's Snapchat or Instagram,
they could post whatever
they want on Instagram,
they could post whatever they want on,
kids have Finstas now
where they only accept 10 kids
and they're posting tons of
different kinds of pictures.
I think it really depends on
the person and what they're,
like for me and my parents, for example,
they always, since when
I first got a phone,
they said, "Whatever you put out there,
"is out there forever."
Whether it's on social media
or even in real life,
whatever you say to someone.
It depends on the person
and I think what they're taught
and what you taught your kids.
And if you trust your kids,
I mean I'm not a parent.
- Listen, you can come
from your perspective.
Look, I think,
and Michelle, I'm so glad you called
because there's so many
interesting conversations here.
Number one, what does society accept?
Let me talk about my career.
Nine years ago,
I started putting out business
videos on the internet.
If you go look at the comments,
I was scolded, Michelle,
scolded for cursing.
It was completely unacceptable
in so many people's eyes.
Now it is just so much more
minor to most people's eyes
than it was just 10 years ago.
So I think the other thing is
who's the judge and the jury?
I am super duper not concerned
about my child being suspended from school
'cause I disrespect the
institution of a high school
and I think things evolve.
I think the question is intent
and who's the kid really
in the scheme of things?
Because I think this,
Michelle, I think you and I can both agree
both of us did some dumb
shit in high school.
- [Michelle] Sure, everybody does
and if they say that they
didn't, they're lying.
- That's exactly right.
So I think what parents have to reconcile,
I think most parents
are actually more worried
about the judgment of other parents
because they know their kid
and they know if they're a
good kid or a troubled kid,
one way or the other,
of how it all plays out.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Michelle] I do
because I tell my kids
I don't care what everybody else thinks,
I only care about you two
and what I think.
I really don't care about
other people's judgment
but I'm just saying as
kids too in this society,
they're being looked at,
girls send nude photos,
it's like someone pulling down,
it's not the same as someone
pulling down your pants
but you're allowing yourself
to show the world everything.
- Listen, and I get that and listen,
no parent wants to have the visual
of their young daughter
sending nude photos to somebody else.
I have unbelievable amounts
of empathy for that.
I think what I'm most fascinated by,
and this is super philosophical,
which I think is always dangerous
because when these things
become real to people,
they're like, that's cute Gary,
that you're talking about
empowerment in an 80 year window
around how social media plays out,
I now have today a 17 year old girl
and I'm worried about this.
So I made a rule a long time ago
about getting into people's business,
not their marriages, not
the way they raise children,
but I will say this,
demonizing platforms
that are exposing you, not changing you,
is something I think parents
need to be more thoughtful
of in 2018, right,
because it's not Snapchat.
- [Michelle] No, it's not Snapchat,
it's just the platform that they're using
to do these things.
- That's right--
- [Michelle] That's all
and I understand that.
- The question is why are
they doing these things?
For example, I ripped apart a mother--
- [Michelle] Popularity.
- Yeah or something else.
I ripped apart a mother privately
who I'm an acquaintance with
who got very upset about my
points of view on social media
and things of that nature
and I was eating it
but I was sitting on something
and just to play it out,
basically I told her in not so many words
maybe if you didn't keep
telling your daughter
when she was eight, nine,
13 and 14 to get skinnier,
maybe she would have
better self body image
and maybe she wouldn't
have played out that way.
So parents love to blame social media
and they love to blame other kids,
but they're not paying attention
when they snap at their
daughter when they're 11
and they're eating a cupcake
and they're reinforcing to their daughter
that that mother has judgment
on that girl's body type.
- [Michelle] Correct, correct.
- I think there's an unbelievable
lack of responsibility
by parents right now
that there's a lot going on
and I just think a lot of parents
don't want to take on accountability
for what they're doing.
- They don't.
- Right, Michelle, you know
this, you're in the trenches.
- [Michelle] No, they don't,
they absolutely don't want
to take on accountability
and they turn the other eye,
they look the other way and
they do the other thing.
- Social media has been the punching bag,
current punching bag of parents
who don't want to take accountability
for the fact that they
did not raise their kids
with enough self esteem
to be able to navigate in
today's world, the end.
- [Michelle] Right, I agree.
- And by the way, Michelle,
let me give you a counter
argument real quick
'cause this has turned into a
very important conversation.
What about--
- [Michelle] There's so
much more to talk here.
This is just surface talk.
- Well, what's funny is
we went down one route.
I gave you the example of
mom making daughter insecure,
thus daughter's looking
for positive reinforcement.
Where is she gonna get it?
From going scandalous to a 15 year old boy
who gives her positive reinforcement.
Let me go the other way.
The other thing that
parents have to recognize
is if you tell your kid that
they're great at everything
when they suck at singing
or when you give them a
ninth place trophy for tennis
and make them feel like they won,
when everyone gets trophies,
when they get to 15, 17, 19, 22
and the world kind of takes over
and they're out of their parents bubble
and they're like, wait a
minute, I'm not the best
and I've never dealt with adversity
and my parents taught me
that adversity is bad,
all of a sudden, they're
crippled by adversity
and they act out in a different way.
This is a very important
time for parents to step up.
Parents are becoming more removed
and selfish about their
own lives than ever
because parents are younger than ever
and they want to still keep on living.
And so what they're doing
is they're pointing fingers
at social media platforms
and it's a very important subject
that we need to talk about more.
- [Michelle] It is extremely important
and this is surface talk
and if you ever want
to talk about it again
I have so much to say about it.
- Well, listen we're here
and we're here right now.
And honestly, I think it's
important because look,
Baby Ariel here has to
sell some fucking books
and I will tell you
that knowing where she
went with this book,
this is a book that I
think parents and kids
both need to read
because it's gonna give them insight.
I've been talking a lot
'cause I'm very passionate about this.
I want Baby Ariel to talk
about the DMs she's getting
from 13, 14, 15 year old girls
and what they're saying
about their parents.
I'm gonna let her do that.
But I'm gonna let you say
something here, Michelle.
You just said you have
something else to say.
Give me another data point
of things that you find fascinating.
- [Michelle] Oh well I'm
just referring to this.
I'm recently divorced
and now I'm at a point in my life
where I have to try to rebuild my life
and then make something for myself
because in just a few years,
my kids are off and on their own
but yet, it's this push and pull
because I don't want to give up my kids
and let's say use the word abandonment,
it's not the right word, abandonment,
but I still need to rebuild my life
but yet still continue to guide them
to make sure that they're
making the right choices
in their future.
I can't just walk away
but there's got to be a balance there.
- That's such a good point,
between what you have
to do professionally,
the fact that you have to now play
in a new personal environment
and you need to be happy
before you can bring any
happiness to your kids,
I mean to your point,
all of these things are so circumstantial.
I love when people point at other people
and say, they wish they were them.
And I'm like, yeah but
tomorrow that person
could become terminally ill.
Nobody knows anybody's details
and that's such a good point.
To me, that's what--
- That's true,
my friends laugh at me.
They laugh at me because
I've become a stair climber
where I climb the World Trade Center,
I climb Empire State Building,
I just applied for the
lottery for the Eiffel Tower,
I go hot air ballooning,
I'm gonna be in the Macy's Day Parade
and holding on to one of those balloons
in the Macy's Day Parade
and I'm hiking, I'm doing all these things
and my kids are like, wow
mom, that's so inspiring.
And I pull them along with me
to do these out-of-the-box type of things
because I think it's really important
not to be pigeon-holed into everything.
But I want to hear about the book.
- Instead of the book for a second
'cause we'll close with that,
tell me and tell everybody who's watching,
who have no fucking idea
because 14 year old Sally
is sending you messages,
they're not walking into
their mom's room and saying,
let me tell you everything.
What are the common themes
when you read stuff
about what kids are saying
about their parents?
- It's a lot of,
I think right now kids,
a lot of pressure
that they're getting
from their parents to,
a lot of comparing their kids
to other children
based on what they see,
I think parents are now
on social media more
and they see other kids.
They go on Facebook and
they see Stacy's kid
and this person's kid
and a lot of comparisons between,
okay, why aren't you
more like this person?
And for this kid they,
being not comfortable with themselves,
they go on social media
to find their comfort
which I don't think is right.
And they compare themselves
again to another kid,
they compare themselves
to every social media,
every magazine model,
every single person on social media
and they're already getting that pressure
from their parents and
they're already getting
what's it called, the
comparison from their parents
and now they're doing it to themselves
which I don't think is right, of course.
I think to go on social media,
one thing I learned,
is you have to be comfortable
with yourself first
and you have to be comfortable enough
to put yourself out there
as who you truly are
or else the comments will get to you.
And then I think also with more parents,
just in terms of school,
they feel a lot of pressure
when it comes to school,
when it comes to why
aren't you doing football,
or why aren't you doing this,
why aren't you doing that?
Why aren't you starting your own whatever?
Because they see all these
other kids doing certain things.
- Right and what's really interesting
is they see all these other kids
and people haven't quantified it.
There are a couple
thousand kids breaking out
and there is tens if not
hundreds of millions of kids.
So people are comparing
themselves to the .1%.
They don't understand the
talent that is involved.
We've quantified the talent
of being LeBron James.
We have not yet quantified the
talent of being Baby Ariel,
we haven't.
Just to give you a nice compliment.
We are not in a stage yet
where we understand being an influencer
and being a travel blogger
is work and talent.
- And now because of the way I think
a lot of social media
influencers present themselves
is oh here's my every day life
and here is me and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah
and this is what I'm doing.
And parents don't understand
why their kid can't do that, for example.
- And kids don't understand
why they can't do that.
- Exactly 'cause they see
us just being ourselves.
- Yeah, they think
they're gonna go outside,
take a picture of their first Instagram,
put a really rad filter on it,
add a couple cute words
and four minutes later,
Nerds candy is gonna
give them 50,000 bucks.
- Exactly, that's it.
- Michelle, thank you for calling.
Good luck with everything.
- [Michelle] Thank you.
- I can't wait to see Michelle
on the Macy's Day Parade.
Let's sneak in one more phone call.
I know we're running out of time
but let's sneak one more in.
What haven't we touched on with the book?
Pick up the book and support Baby Ariel.
What haven't we touched on the book
that you think might bring value?
Who is the target reader for you
or who is somebody who
might get value from this
that maybe people aren't thinking about?
- Let me think.
- How young do you think this book can go?
Let's go there.
- I want to say--
- What's your gut tell you?
- Nine, eight around
because it's not, I have a lot
of stories in there about me
but I think people can take those stories
and they can see what I
was feeling in that time
and relate to what I was feeling.
It's not just about self love,
but it's also about school
and your family, for example,
and family problems that I have,
about my grandparents
and about dealing with
friends and friend break ups,
when somebody isn't being nice to you.
- Do you talk about boy
relationships in there?
- Oh 100%
about this boy who wasn't treating me well
and I think kids now are getting
into relationships younger
and they can relate to
friends being mean to them
and boys not treating them well
and they can read this book and understand
okay, it's not,
I want them to read this book and know
that it's not just them.
- If you're going through it--
- Exactly, then they can
because I don't think,
a lot of kids now because of social media
they isolate themselves more
and they're more into their
phones and their YouTube
and they watch a lot more
and they're on their phone,
when they're not interacting
with other people--
- Yeah, but good news, this notion, guys,
I'm 42 years old,
people went in their room,
locked the door, watched MTV
and played Nintendo all day.
I don't understand this nirvana,
unless you're 90 fucking years old,
there is no nirvana
that kids went outside and played all day.
Leave it To Beaver was
100 fucking years ago.
This notion that these parents of you,
and I remember, my favorite
part of when you came out
which was like oh shit,
'cause even earlier I was like us,
and I was talking like
you and me are the same.
Your parents were like younger than me.
To me, this notion,
if you're a parent of
a nine to 20 year old,
fuck you and I mean this,
this notion that you lived in this world
where everybody went outside.
Let me tell you about the '80s.
No kid went outside
because that's when kidnappings started
and America's Most Wanted started
and everybody stayed inside.
What the hell do you
think happened with MTV?
Two-way phones, phone lines for girls,
video games came out in the '80s.
Guys, once and for all,
this go outside and play shit is bullshit.
It's bullshit, it's not been around
for a very, very, very, very long time.
It's a long time since boys
played stick ball in Brooklyn.
We're talking about a
time a long time ago.
The social media
demonization is laughable.
It was called the television.
Here's what people did in 1984,
they went in their room, they watched TV,
they played video games and
you know what Instagram is?
It's Seventeen Magazine and Vogue.
They went through magazines over and,
you know what your
fucking Explore feature is
on Instagram and your News Feed is,
it's a magazine.
You know what's better about this magazine
than the one I grew up with?
The pictures change.
Because you would look at the same source
and Sports Illustrated
and all the dog shit,
it is time for us to put this to bed.
This world that parents
have made up in their head
that is their,
49 year old, parent, you
didn't live this world,
your parents did.
You now made pretend 'cause you're scared
'cause you love your kids so much
that you can't breathe
and thus you go fearful
but enough of this isolation,
kids were isolated,
guys, the fuck do you
think grunge rock was?
You know what happened
in fucking 1989 and '90?
All kids did was listen
to depressing shit.
Go listen to Kurt Cobain,
go listen to fucking Black Hole Sun.
What is the matter with everybody here?
Kids are always isolated.
They've been isolated.
The hell do you think the Beatles were?
What do you think is going on?
This notion that anything's changed,
when you are 10, when you are 13 to 20,
a lot happens, the end.
And what I'll tell you is,
here's what's changed,
parents are either micromanaging
their kids too much
or not paying attention to them too much.
We've lost balance at the parent level
out of selfishness from parents
and they want to blame fucking
Snapchat and Instagram.
We need accountability on parents
to get out of their kid's business,
or get into their kid's business,
'cause there's no fucking balance, period,
that's the truth.
Baby Ariel.
- Yeah!
- Fuck.
- [Andy] We have Robert on the line.
- Good, Robert?
- [Robert] Hey Gary, hey
Gary, how are you doing?
- Sorry about that rant, man, sorry bro.
- [Robert] It was a good rant
because I totally agree with it.
My daughter is 11 turning 12
and she's very well known actually
through me through social media
'cause I've had her on live
streaming and other things
and she's really building
on the old Musical.ly.
- And I'm listening, keep going.
- [Robert] Oh okay, I
saw the arm go across
like maybe I was still muted.
- No, go ahead, the arm's,
you're on delay on video, keep talking,
we're live here baby.
You know how on radio
they used to be like,
turn down the audio.
I'm telling you to stop watching
the video, it's no delay,
keep talking, go ahead.
- [Robert] So she's been
building on Musical.ly
which Baby Ariel, you probably know,
is now called TikTok.
- Yes.
- [Robert] And they seem to
be changing a lot of things
and I don't know if
you're finding that also,
that she was building strong really fast,
she's up to 1,100 followers,
she's trying to build her YouTube channel,
she started it last year
and she's a singer like you Ariel.
In fact, she's excited to see you
tomorrow night in Livingston.
- Oh yeah, I'm excited
to see her, tell her.
- [Robert] Yep, I will,
I will tell Reina to say hi.
- Hi, hi Reina.
- [Robert] But she's
finding the struggles now
because I don't know if
you've seen it, Gary,
that the bots are now
starting to hit on Musical.ly
where they do a follow
and then they unfollow.
So she sees her numbers go up and down,
up and down all the time.
- Brother, let me tell
you something right now,
I'm gonna cut you off, I apologize,
you have to at all costs
sit her down day after
day, hour after hour,
and tell her, and you have to eliminate
her having any validation
by engagement numbers or following count
because if you allow her to care about it,
it's game over.
Brother, I promise you with all my heart,
I want you guys to win,
finding validation from
how many people follow you
or how many people like your posts,
is the death trap of this game.
- I think that for me being
someone on social media
that was one of the hardest
hurdles that I had to get over.
It used to be where I would go online
and look for sometimes my
self love and my confidence
in the likes that I was getting
and sometimes they would go down,
sometimes they would go up
and I'm telling you right now,
as someone who did care
and as someone who got down on myself
because of the likes and the numbers,
you have to tell her
that that does not matter
'cause it goes in waves.
And summer happens, for example,
kids are on their phones
more, the likes will go up.
School starts, the likes will go down
because they're at school more.
Mid-terms are happening, the likes will,
it goes in so many
different kinds of ways.
- And let me jump in here.
The thing that really scares me brother,
especially for an 11, 12 year old girl,
why you have to not allow
them to be validated
by this engagement
is when they get sucked in,
and by the way, 99% of people
from the ages of nine to 99
are suckered by this, I'm telling you,
I would argue that this has
been the single biggest reason
that I've been happy and successful,
that I never was,
because I knew that they were just a proxy
and gamified and all this dirty stuff,
engagement group, all the horseshit,
here's what you're
really gonna worry about,
if she starts worrying
about engagement numbers and following
it's gonna lead her to doing things
like showing more skin, being more,
you're gonna go to lowest
common denominator things
and then that's like cliche girl stuff.
Forget about even that,
both girls and boys,
you're gonna go into things
that are pandering for likes
and you're gonna limit your creativity.
I get excited, my team'll tell you,
I get excited when we
do poorly in engagement
because I know we took a creative risk
or did something new
and we learned from it.
It's like science.
The nos are sometimes
better than the yeses.
But when your self
esteem's wrapped into it,
you become one-dimensional
and all of a sudden,
I get these DMs all the time,
31 year old women saying,
"Gary I can't grow my account
unless I show my ass."
And I'm like, "Don't show your fucking ass
"unless you're in the
showing ass business."
I'm telling you right now,
the reason I don't care
about bots or anything else,
they don't matter to me
because that is not the currency.
The currency is loving the
process of what you're doing
and then what are you
actually trying to accomplish
with all the attention and following?
Are you building a business?
Are you trying to become
a known expert in a field?
What are you trying to do with it?
It's depth versus width.
You have to, brother, right
now, off this phone call,
you have to, and not in dad way of like,
hey daughter, don't care
about the likes and followers,
no, no, way deeper of like,
let me tell you why the likes
and followers don't matter
because what we're actually
trying to accomplish,
if you want to be a singer,
it's not gonna be people get
signed with 5,000 followers.
Justin Bieber only had
60,000 views on YouTube
when Scooter signed him on his posts.
So it comes in all shapes and sizes
but you will lose the self esteem game
if you value yourself
based on likes and follows
and unfortunately 99% of people do.
- One thing that really helped me
when I was just starting,
and my parents and I actually do this
pretty much every year is when I,
or even when I'm low on myself,
we'll sit down with a huge piece of paper
and write down a game plan and my goals
and what I want to work on,
what I want to get better at
and my demographic.
Who am I trying to reach
and what am I trying to do?
Do I want the numbers
or do I want five people
and I want to make
those five people happy?
Because everything will come organically
and it's going to happen if,
you just have to remain true,
and also I don't want her, make sure,
I don't want her to go online
and get deeper into this hole
of finding her validation on social media.
Just if she needs a break from
social media, that's fine.
- Are you, you're 17?
- [Baby Ariel] Yeah.
- Right so let's use Baby
Ariel 'cause she's right here,
clearly her content is gonna be different,
she's 17, she's Baby
Ariel, let's play it out,
clearly her posts are gonna be different
if she's looking for attention from boys
and wants to go that route
versus she wants to be a dominant player
for 12 year old girls.
It's not super complicated.
And we've seen it with Nickelodeon stars
over and over and over again.
They start their careers,
they're of a certain mindset and age
and ambition professionally
and they crush it
for eight to 13 year old girls
and then after scratching that itch
or achieving their goals
and they're 17 or 18,
they want to then get attention from boys
and you can see the transformation
happen in your eyes,
like literally black and white.
And so what's important about that,
just to use her as an example is,
your content needs to speak
for what you're trying to achieve.
And those things that
you're trying to achieve,
change over time.
And the cliche thing is,
you go for that audience,
then you go for, let's just play it out,
you go for those teeny bopper girls,
then you go for boys,
then you go back for
the teeny bopper girls.
You see it over and over again.
The bottom line is everybody's actions
will play out in their posts.
You have to watch them carefully.
I don't need to have every
access to my kid's accounts.
What they put out publicly,
and I have a big advantage,
I knew about Finstagram,
Finsta was like,
first it was called
Finstagram five years ago,
now it's gained a lot of popularity
because kids have left Snapchat
and so Finsta matters more
because really they
used Snapchat as Finsta.
And so it's really fun
to watch it all evolve.
Here's what I know,
kids are always gonna hide from parents
and that's healthy, that's healthy.
You just have to instill the right virtues
and I promise you brother,
you allowing your daughter
to care about followers and likes
is a very, very vulnerable place
and you need to get out of that ASAP.
- [Robert] Okay, I try to tell her
it doesn't matter all the time
but it's hard at that age.
- No shit but guess what?
You have to be religious about it
and, and, you calling this show
and asking about the bots on Musical.ly
means that you're further
into it than you should be
from my perspective, I could be wrong,
you raise your daughter
the way you want to,
but I want you to win and I like your vibe
and I'm telling you that
is the line in the sand.
Fuck those numbers.
- [Robert] I brought it up
only 'cause that's what I,
I do similar to you,
social media for a living.
So I know about the bots.
So I was like I'm watching--
- Ready?
Let's get rid of the
kids, it's now me and you
and talking about our
careers, fuck the numbers.
- [Robert] Oh, I don't care
about the numbers at all.
- Good, then fuck bots.
- [Robert] Yeah, I personally don't
but it's trying to explain it
to an 11 year old sometimes
'cause she's at that preteen,
there's times I feel like I'm
talking to a 30 year old girl
and many people if they're
watching, friends of this,
they feel all the time--
- Sometimes she's 18,
sometimes she's 18 months,
that's right.
I get it brother.
- Exactly,
it's that in-between stage.
- I get it brother.
Good luck, man.
- Good luck.
- Thanks Gary,
bye bye Gary.
- Final thoughts, Ariel.
- By the way, are you ever
gonna drop the baby part.
I've been thinking a lot about this.
This was something I wanted to ask you,
I was thinking about this.
I was like, oh, she's
gonna be like those rappers
that have to drop the prefix,
you know how like, I'm trying to think of,
like who's a good one,
like there hasn't been a bunch.
- [Male] Bow Wow.
- Yeah, Bow Wow.
It's just fun when people
have to drop the lil.
Have you thought about dropping it
or do you want to go the other way
and just own it in perpetuity?
- I think I'm gonna just own it for now.
Honestly, right now, it's
who I am, it's working.
Unless there's a real reason, like okay,
if it's working, it's working.
- More importantly, there's
nothing wrong with it.
I was just super curious if
it's run through your mind.
- I mean it has for sure
because I'm almost 18
like okay, I'm not a baby anymore.
- Yeah, but I mean what's good about baby,
it's not like kind of like lil,
you can kind of like,
as a matter of fact, I actually think
maybe you should go deeper into it
so that every kid coming up
uses baby the way everyone used lil.
- Yeah, hopefully, I don't know,
we can make it something.
- There has to be a bunch
of nine year old girls
named Baby Sarah.
- I saw a few Instagram
kids who do the Instagram
and their name was like baby
something, exactly yeah.
And I was like, okay, if
we can make it a thing,
let's just make it a thing.
- I remember a couple of people
did the two silent E's in business
'cause I did it with Gary Vee
and I literally DM'ed them, I was like,
no, no, no, no, no, that
was a huge mistake of mine,
silent vowels are terrible, get out of it.
Anyway, it's really great to have you.
- So nice to be here,
thank you for having me.
- What's your question
of the day?
Guests get to ask the question of the day.
What's your question for the VaynerNation?
- Ooh, I guess, what
are you passionate about
and what do you dream about,
what do you want to perceive
and what's your passion?
- [Gary] I love it,
thanks for being on the show.
- That's my question.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)